Traductor: Sheila Pardo Calzas
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Les voy a contar algo
que probablemente les parezca inverosímil,
pero que es cierto.
Yo estuve en un escenario,
en un escenario como este,
antes de nacer.
Tal cual.
Iba en el vientre de mi madre
mientras ella actuaba en obras teatrales.
Soy, pues, hijo de una actriz,
nieto, bisnieto,
tataranieto de actores y de actrices,
eso por un lado.
Por el otro, soy hijo de un hombre judío
al que no conocí,
un hombre al que apenas pude ver
unos cuantos minutos
durante mi adolescencia.
Un hombre que no supo,
o no pudo estar conmigo.
Así es que, la extraña ecuación afectiva
que me dio a luz,
es una suerte de historia prohibida entre
un hombre judío y una mujer católica
en el México de los años 60,
y el resultado, el producto
de esa historia fue un niño.
Un niño peculiar, solitario,
imaginativo, valiente,
al que le faltaban piezas
de su rompecabezas;
piezas que a los demás niños
no les faltaban.
Un niño que se esforzaba por entender
por qué su cuento no cuadraba,
y ¿por qué no cuadraba el cuento?
Porque, por un lado, vivía
una realidad cotidiana llena de ficción
con actores y actrices, fundamentalmente
actrices mujeres, que no entendían
dónde empezaba la vida real
y dónde terminaba el teatro.
Así, esos desayunos de ese niño que soy,
que fui, que sigo siendo yo,
no se podían distinguir
muy claramente de una tragedia griega,
o de una obra de Federico García Lorca.
Y, por el otro lado, en ese cuento,
el niño se tenía que imaginar
un mundo real judío,
el de su padre y sus hermanos
que vivían en la misma ciudad que él.
Él lo sabía en ese mismo momento.
Un mundo real pero ficticio,
verdadero pero inalcanzable,
prohibido, vedado.
Y la manera en la que ese niño
intentó hacer conciliar la historia,
en la que intentó hacer
que el rompecabezas tomara forma,
en la que trató de explicarse
por qué era como era, qué le pasaba,
qué había hecho que sucedieran esas cosas,
pero, sobre todo, la manera
en la que se pudo enfrentar
al siempre hostil mundo de los niños,
fue saliendo a buscar
las piezas del rompecabezas
y, al no encontrarlas, inventándolas.
Inventando sus primeras ficciones.
O a lo mejor, inventándose a sí mismo
como una ficción.
Así, un día, de buenas a primeras,
en la escuela, frente a sus compañeros,
transformó a su padre ausente
en un soldado israelí,
que peleaba batallas heróicamente
en un desierto de Medio Oriente.
O, yendo un poco más lejos, otro día
sustrajo una kipá de una sinagoga,
y se la empezó a poner
en la cabeza, a escondidas,
antes de entrar al salón de clases,
cuando nadie lo veía,
para entrar así frente a sus compañeros.
Por obra y gracia de la ficción,
ese niño se había convertido en otra cosa.
Había pasado de ser un niño sin padre
a transformarse en un niño judío,
hijo de un héroe militar.
Acababa de descubrir la magia
y el poder de la ficción,
y empezó a caminar
por ese camino, por ese sendero.
Pronto, empezó a escribir historias
en pequeños cuadernos,
en donde animaba, le daba vida
a los objetos que lo rodeaban:
un timbre postal se angustiaba
porque se despegaba de una carta;
una pluma, no una pluma cualquiera,
la pluma de Beethoven
se conmovía al ver como los sentimientos
de ese genio se transformaban
a través de ella, en música.
Eso es lo que el niño hacía.
Pero, lo que estaba haciendo ese niño,
ese yo, era realmente construir espejos
en los que se reflejaba él mismo,
sus angustias, sus miedos,
sus deseos, sus fantasias.
Fue un poco más lejos cuando apareció
su primer ángel de la guarda:
mi tía Alicia, la hermana de mi madre,
que un día me regaló
una máquina de escribir,
para que me convirtiera
verdaderamente en un gran escritor.
Rápidamente me puse a trabajar sobre ella,
seguro de que iba a escribir
una obra maestra.
Y un buen día, llamé a mi tía y le dije:
«He escrito un cuento genial, escúchalo».
Se lo leí, y no pude creer su respuesta;
seria, pero dulce, me dijo
que lo que le estaba leyendo era,
prácticamente palabra por palabra,
un cuento famoso de los hermanos Grimm.
Un plagio, literalmente.
Todavía recuerdo a ese niño
llorando desconsolado y negando eso.
Todavía hoy, delante de ustedes,
juro que creo que yo escribí ese cuento.
Acababa de descubrir
que la ficción es pública pero privada.
Acababa de descubrir el derecho de autor,
la propiedad intelectual,
y no me hacía ninguna gracia.
Pero pude superar
ese primer fracaso literario,
pude reponerme.
¿Saben cómo?
Empecé a descrubrir que podía pilotar
unas naves de ficción increíbles,
unas naves que se llaman
ópera, teatro, literatura, cine, ballet,
y que con ellas podía empezar
a armar modelos,
a generar modelos que me faltaban,
modelos masculinos, modelos de paternidad,
modelos de amor al padre, de fraternidad,
de amor de pareja...
Pero no solo eso, empecé a generar
mis códigos sociales, políticos,
emocionales fundamentalmente.
Y además, atravesando toda mi adolescencia
en esas naves, llegué a una isla,
una isla superpoblada
de seres maravillosos,
de seres que al mismo tiempo
eran reales pero no,
que se podían tocar,
pero no se podían tocar,
que existían, pero no existían,
y que se llamaban personajes.
Y dentro de esos personajes descubrí
que existe uno que se llama tiempo;
que el tiempo es un personaje,
el más caprichoso de todos,
que iba para delante, para atrás,
que subía, que bajaba,
que a veces iba en sentidos contrarios,
y ahí descubrí que el tiempo
es un invento humano muy equivocado,
y que los relojes como ese que me
está amenazando son una verdadera mentira.
Eso es lo que entendí.
Y así, caminando por ese sendero, insisto,
llegué por supuesto a mi primer beso,
al momento en el que pude besar a la
chica de la adolescencia a la que amaba,
¿Dónde?, frente a una ficción,
como era previsible, en un cine,
frente a una película romántica,
cumplí ante esa fantasía
mi fantasía de tanto tiempo,
y logré llegar a ese día maravilloso,
eterno, que no termina de terminar.
Y así, de ficción en ficción
llegué a mi primer libro publicado.
«Tríptico: (tres actos en una ópera)»,
donde, como se pueden imaginar,
lo que estaba haciendo era explorar
la diferencia o la dificultad para
diferenciar la vida real de la ficción;
en ese caso de la ópera, que es así,
hoy será, una de las grandes pasiones
de mi vida.
Pero realmente lo que estaba haciendo
era entender que escribir ficción
no es inventar historias;
es escribirse a uno mismo,
corregirse, mejorarse,
convertirse en quien uno quiere ser,
o dejar de ser
quien uno ya no quiere dejar de ser.
Seguí en ese terreno, y pasaron diez años.
Diez años es el período habitual
que me lleva publicar un nuevo libro.
No sé si es mucho o es poco, pero es así;
es algo que se cumple rigurosamente.
Y llego al segundo libro, que se titula
«No honrarás a tu padre», una novela.
Les debe sonar bastante lógico, ¿no?
Después de esta impúdica confesión
que les he hecho.
Pensarán que es una novela autobiográfica.
Pues no, no lo es, no es
una autobiografía; es un autoretrato.
Que no es lo mismo.
¿Y saben por qué?
Porque lo que dice el libro
son puras mentiras.
Una tras otra, tras otra, tras otra.
El 90% del libro son mentiras.
Y sin embargo cuentan mi historia
con una fidelidad misteriosa.
Ahí entendí que eso es la literatura:
un mentir, y mentir, y mentir
para poder decir la verdad.
Y que tenemos muy sobrevalorada
a veces la verdad,
y muy injustamente subvalorada la mentira.
Pasaron otros diez años, y llegué
a mi siguiente, y más reciente libro:
«Éxtasis: una novela en siete cápsulas».
¿Qué estaba haciendo con esa novela?
Estaba ahora mintiendo desde la ciencia.
Hablando de la química de las emociones.
¿Por qué?, porque además
de estudiar piano, estudié bioquímica.
Sí, es rara la combinación.
Y no termino de entender
por qué estudié bioquímica.
No lo terminaba de entender, si sabía
que nunca iba a ejercer esa carrera.
¿Y saben cuándo lo entendí?
Cuando vi la novela publicada.
Entendí que había estudido bioquímica
para escribir la novela.
Que era como si la novela
me hubiera escrito a mí
estudiando bioquímica
para poderla escribir.
Como si la novela se estuviera
autoescribiendo a través de mí.
Como la famosa mano, el dibujo de Escher,
en el que una mano dibuja a una mano
que la dibuja dibujándola, revirtiendo,
destruyendo, cancelando el tiempo.
¿Esto quiere decir que soy
un escritor lento, perezoso, ocasional...?
No, no es así.
Todo el tiempo estuve escribiendo.
Todos ustedes,
todos estamos escribiendo todo el tiempo:
en el cine, en el baño,
en el trabajo, en la mesa
cuando estamos desayunando con la familia,
cuando hacemos el amor;
ese es un terreno muy fértil
para la imaginación y para la ficción,
aunque no lo digamos.
Todos, todos somos unas verdaderas
máquinas de ficción, cotidianamente.
Y la prueba más grande de eso,
es el sueño. Es soñar.
Cuando estamos dormidos,
en nuestra situación más vulnerable,
más indefensa;
tal vez en nuestro estado más puro,
estamos inventando ficciones.
En ese momento en el que nuestro cerebro
desecha memorias temporales
y consolida memorias permanentes,
inventamos historias.
Guau, realmente es increíble.
Me detengo un momento y me pregunto
ante ustedes de qué estoy hablando.
¿Estoy hablando realmente
de ficciones de arte? No.
¿Saben de qué estoy hablando?
Estoy hablando del otro,
del OTRO con mayúsculas,
de los otros, de todos esos
que están a nuestro alrededor
y que nos conforman,
y a los que nosotros también hacemos.
Todos esos otros, que es lo que
la ficción nos permite tener.
Entrar en contacto con esos otros,
vivir con ellos, amar con ellos,
sufrir con ellos...
Y también morir con ellos.
Finalmente, este entrar en contacto
con los demás, con los otros,
es lo que llamamos empatía.
¿Qué es la empatía?
La ciencia lo ha definido; dice que es un
cóctel neuroquímico en el que se dispara
la serotonina para sentir más amor
por los demás, más paz, más dulzura.
En el que baja la dopamina para que
sintamos menos comportamientos agresivos,
en el que sube la oxitocina para que
sintamos confianza en los demás.
Sin embargo,
también hay otras definiciones.
El arte, la literatura también definen
la empatía y ese estar con el otro.
Y quién mejor que Octavio Paz,
nuestro Premio Nobel de Literatura,
que lo dice con una frase maravillosa
que desde hace años no puedo olvidar
en su poema Piedra de sol:
«Para que sea yo, he de ser otro,
salir de mí, buscarme entre los otros,
los otros que no son si yo no existo,
los otros, que me dan plena existencia».
Fin de la cita.
Pero no solo son los escritores, no solo
son los artistas los que hacen ficción.
Piensen en la ciencia, piensen
en un Newton, un Einstein, un Hawking.
Piensen en el Big Ban,
en los agujeros negros,
en los plieges espacio-tiempo
gravitatorios einstenianos.
¿Qué es eso?
Cuentos, son ficciones.
Se estaban contando a sí mismos un cuento
porque no cuadraba tampoco su rompecabezas
y luego lo llenaron de ciencia,
de matemáticas, de física,
y pudieron contarlo.
Piensen, por ejemplo, también
en los grandes deportistas,
en los deportistas de élite,
en mi idolatrado Messi.
En esos goles de fantasía,
en esos pases y jugadas inimaginables.
Por supuesto
que ese hombre también escribe,
por supuesto que está haciendo ficción
como todos los grandes deportistas,
como un Michael Jordan;
al menos una fracción de segundo antes
de lograr esas jugadas, se las imaginan,
y luego las trazan con su cuerpo.
Piensen en los movimientos sociales,
piensen en Martin Luther King,
¿qué dijo Martin Luther King?
¿Dijo, tengo una teoría?
¿Tengo un concepto?
¿Tengo un proyecto?
Dijo «I have a dream», tengo un sueño,
tengo una ficción, tengo un cuento.
Y le pidió a un pueblo entero
que le ayudara a contarlo.
Vivimos en un país terriblemente violento
y creo que eso puede cambiar con ficción.
Infundiendo la buena ficción,
la buena literatura, el buen teatro,
la buena ópera, el buen cine.
Porque hoy sabemos que consumir
esa buena ficción genera el mismo
cóctel de neuroquímicos que nos permite
sentir empatía, y también sabemos,
científicamente demostrado,
que si sentimos empatía por alguien,
no lo podemos lastimar,
no lo podemos agredir;
aquí está la ecuación.
A mayor buena ficción, mayor empatía,
y a mayor empatía,
menores comportamientos delictivos.
No podemos hacer nada,
ni lo más cotidiano,
ni lo más ordinario,
ni lo más heróico,
si no nos lo imaginamos antes.
Finalmente, quiero pedirles
algunos favores.
Quiero pedirles que hagan algo.
Quiero pedirles que crean en la ficción,
porque siempre
les va a decir algo de ustedes.
Quiero que estimulen, que encaucen,
que alienten a los jóvenes,
a sus hermanos, a sus hijos,
a ustedes mismos, a sus padres
a consumir buena ficción;
siempre les va a enseñar quienes son.
Vivan ficción, naden en la ficción,
háganle el amor a la ficción,
suden ficción, respiren ficción;
va a ser su mejor maestra
porque siempre, siempre, les va a enseñar
algo sin proponer enseñárselo.
¿Quieren cambiar?
¿Quieren ser mejores?
¿Quieren hacer un gran proyecto,
una gran obra, un gran producto,
una gran empresa?
Primero, cuéntensela.
Imagínensela, y después,
escríbanla con su vida.
Y recuerden estas palabras,
recuérdenlas muy bien:
Todas las historias que se han escrito,
se escriben y se escribirán,
han empezado, empiezan y empezarán
siempre, siempre, con las mismas palabras:
Érase una vez... yo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)